matpat theorize in in the mornin and
we're back early birds later on in
today's show we'll have a preview of
Greendale's hottest theme dances coming
up this semester I'm personally looking
forward to Dean Pelton's floss Athan for
cavity prevention it's sure to make
plenty of human beings out there open up
and say ah yeah
but first let's all loosen up our belts
because we've finally cracked the case
of Greendale's most notorious criminal
that's right human beings we're cashing
in on the identity of the butt crack
bandit which you know is called
something else in the show but YouTube
is stricter than mainstream media so
gotta stay brand safe and you can keep
the change on that one back after these
messages Matt Pat theorize it in the
morn and hello Internet welcome to film
theory way more than six seasons still
waiting on that movie boil theorists get
ready cuz today we're gonna be dropping
some quarter-sized nuggets of knowledge
down your unsuspecting brain pants
there's a crime of foot in the halls of
Greendale Community College and it's up
to us to finally crack the case of the
serial cracker in the event that you
have literally no idea of what I've been
talking about for the first couple
minutes of this episode let me introduce
you to my favorite TV show of all time
community now if you're a subscriber to
this channel chances are you're a fan of
Rick and Morty let's face it the
viewership numbers on those episodes
don't lie and if you like Rick and Morty
then there is a very very high
likelihood that you'll also love
yourself some community as well because
it was created by the same guy Dan
Harmon I'm staying in the sleep study
lab all I have to do is wake up every
three hours and go and I get two credits
but now it is back on Netflix for all of
you to pour directly into your eye holes
to catch you up the show is about a
dysfunctional community college study
group constructed of weirdos and
outcasts the show itself is incredibly
meta and pays homage to just about every
film and television trope you can think
of from iconic paintball episodes
riffing on 80s action movies like die
hard and chicken finger heists that are
inspired by mafia movies like Goodfellas
- claymation Christmas specials and even
classic 8-bit video games while he's
fighting for greed we're fighting for
friendship which means we can't lose
okay okay
I guess there's no hug button it's also
notorious for having some of the most
intricate and patient meta jokes in all
of television history I mean this is a
show where entire plot lines can happen
in the background and go completely
unnoticed if you aren't paying attention
which brings us to the episode that I
wanted to focus on today season fives
basic inner gluteal numismatics a
mystery episode riffing on the tropes of
dark
David Fincher esque films like seven and
Zodiac but unlike those films horrific
murders the threat that lurks in
communities halls is much more mundane
an evil that terrorizes Greendale
Community College by sneaking up on
people who have exposed a little bit of
butt crack and then dropping quarters
into the resulting slot a move known on
campus as cracking because of the nature
of his crimes he's referred to as the
ass crack bandit whom will hereafter be
referring to as the ACB or just the
Bandit because it turns out YouTube
censors or even harsher than NBC's in
the Fincher movies that communities
parroting here there are red herrings
subtle clues galore that have to be
looked at inside and out and still might
not lead to a solution and the same is
the case with this particular episode by
the end of inner gluteal numismatics the
case is left as wide open as the back of
an ill-fitting pair of jeans
the ACB escapes unidentified it's an
incredibly frustrating dangling loose
end to the story of the show one that I
hope to finally tie up with today's
video now don't get me wrong it is an
incredibly difficult mystery to solve
but as Troy himself says all difficult
things are better like carrying a
disease or holding in a fart right now
the bandits main episode is in season
five but we actually know that the ACB
was active on Greendale's campus as of
season two because any references the
bandit in her speech while running for
student body president if I'm elected
the assailant known only as the ass
crack bandit will be brought to justice
if you go frame-by-frame and pause
during the opening credits montage of
news articles about the crime spree you
learned that there were no less than
seven cracking in seven weeks during
that first wave you also get yourself a
partial list of victim names you even
learned that the butt crack bandit was
not the serial fountain pooper there are
two different crime sprees eventually
the Bandit just stops for reasons
unexplained and disappears for over a
year
the season 5 episode kicks off with a
new cracking
during the reopening of Shirley's
sandwich shop shortly afterward troy
becomes the next victim of the bandit
prompting the dean to propose Troy's law
which would put cameras in Greendale's
bathrooms but at a rally for Troy's law
another student named Vicky is cracked
in the bleachers sending the entire
school into a panic annie believes that
ACB has access to the teachers lounge
and convinces jeff to team up to
investigate discovering an important
detail hidden in the bandits letters i
am the mad hatter
if hats were buts to me you're all like
ants marching to class freaks on parade
I mean why mix metaphors ants don't have
butts wait a minute do have butts no
these are Dave lyrics
Dave Dave Matthews hardcore fans : Dave
they're eventually led to starburns who
quickly confesses to the crime but Jeff
learns that he's not a Dave Matthews
Band fan and only confessed as part of a
deal with the Dean
after creeping on Annie in his office
aren't you going to pick those up
professor Duncan is correct in the
hallway Jeff and Annie pursue the
assailant but the Bandit gets away and
the case goes cold
also Chang walks around backwards eating
a giant churro and wearing a fake butt
which leads to nothing in the
investigation but does lead to one of
the strangest and funniest moments in
the show's history extra large sure
tastes good in my real mouth no it feels
safe to say that we can eliminate people
who themselves got cracked so that
immediately eliminates both Troy and
professor Duncan narrowing our field of
potential suspects down to ten
we don't have tons of hard evidence to
use in this case but we can do most of
the work of eliminating suspects by
using what in criminology are called the
three indicators of suspicion means
opportunity and motive means is all
about having the tools necessary to
commit the crime and it's not exactly
like quarters are particularly hard to
come by means though also relates to the
physical capabilities of the suspect and
that one is helpful because it
immediately gets rid of Pierce as a
potential candidate in season two when
the bandit first becomes active Pierce
is confined to a breath powered
wheelchair and let's just say he's not
great at maneuvering around there's no
chance that he's gonna be able to sneak
up on anybody in this thing so he's
immediately off our list opportunity
most closely aligns with alibi
if you're accounted for during the crime
we can safely eliminate you in the
opening of the episode Shirley Dean
Pelton and Chang are all in the
cafeteria for the ribbon-cutting of
Shirley's sandwiches and when Garrett
runs in from having just been cracked
all three of them are still visibly
there that knocks another three suspects
off our list it also can't be star burns
and not just because he can't recognize
Dave Matthews Band lyrics when duncan
gets cracked star burns are still
locking in his cage in the cafeteria
being pelted with change so that now
leaves us with five potential suspects
remaining Hickey Jeff Britta Annie and
Abed now examining motive forces us to
be a little bit more subjective and
connect more dots considering things
like victimology in the pattern of the
Krakens and when it comes to motive
Hickey just makes no sense sure he has
access to the faculty lounge he has a
background in criminology and he
recognizes Dave Matthews Band when he
hears them at the end of season five I
mean real fans just call him Dave but
still he knows the band
the thing is though the pattern of
attacks doesn't really make sense if
hickeys been at Greendale for 15 years
why would he start cracking in season
two stop for seasons three and four and
then start up again in season five he's
also not the type to find this sort of
thing funny he's not really the type to
find many things funny to be honest but
most importantly of all knocking Hickey
out of contention is the ACB's phone
call to Dean Pelton where he
specifically calls out the relationship
between Jeff and any more friends buzz
Hickey in the Canon of the show just met
Jeff one episode ago and as such has a
less than zero stake in the bond again
off again relationship between Jeff and
Annie thereby buzzes off the list this
phone call is also a key piece of
evidence throwing both Jeff and Annie
into question I mean they're both in the
room when it happens so they're not the
ones making the call that said I guess
it could have been pre-recorded so we'll
need more to fully eliminate them from
contention so let's look at the man who
wasn't put in the effort to do something
nearly this elaborate Jeff Winger when
it comes to motive problems he's the
character who struggles to find a motive
to do anything as such sustaining a
prank over multiple years just isn't
Jeff's style and well he has no real
alibi for the Krakens he has
access to the faculty lounge he knows
Dave Matthews Band lyrics and may
subconsciously be looking for an excuse
to spend time with Annie the rest just
doesn't add up why would he fight
against starburns his confession why
would he go looking for the bandits
laptop with a message recorded on it if
he was the one who planted it there in
the first place
none of these have a particularly good
answer and as such Jeff is just
logically off the list Danny on the
other hand is a suspect that requires a
much closer look if her hope is to pull
the Krakens in order to get Jeff to
define their relationship that complaint
on the bandits phone call makes a lot
more sense she's also the one who comes
to the realization at the end of the
episode that the bandit might be a girl
don't worry I got a feeling he'll be
back
[Music]
is it a realization that it could be a
girl or a slip-up admitting that it's
her honestly this moment in the episode
is too vague to tell but what isn't
vague is her reaction in the final
episode of the series when Jeff brings
up the ACB one final time and annie has
herself a very suspicious reaction you
remember the ass crack bandit doesn't
everybody but the most damning piece of
evidence of all against Annie comes from
the script itself when fans question
what the deal was with Annie's awkward
reaction in the final episode community
writer Alex Ruebens did this picture
supposedly from the episode script that
seems like it should be an open and shut
case write the script for the final
episode of the series outright says that
she was probably the band at the entire
time and yet I am convinced that it
wasn't her and I have the evidence to
prove it Annie
being obsessed with a Seabee case keeps
a scrapbook binder of all the key
newspaper coverage pieces of evidence
and her own theories in the episode that
scrapbook is only shown for a few
minutes during the opening credits crawl
but that prop went on auction back in
2017 selling for the not too shabby
price of 800 bucks as a part of the
auction loss they displayed high
resolution photos of what is actually
inside the binder some of which are
never-before-seen pages that didn't make
it into the episode and in those we
actually see two full pages of Annie's
thoughts on the case not only would it
be insane for her to be keeping such
meticulous notes and theories on a crime
spree she herself was committing but
what's more interesting isn't what she's
writing
it's how she's writing it throughout the
episode we're read multiple notes
written by the ACV but were actually
shown two of them one at the top of the
episode and a second later in the
episode that in order to actually read
you have to pause flip and color correct
and for both of those letters Annie's
scrapbook handwriting just doesn't match
the ACB's letter handwriting and this
isn't just me overthinking things either
since in zodiac one of the David Fincher
movies that this episode is parodying
handwriting is the damning final piece
of evidence so it makes sense that it's
important for solving this episode's
little miss
long story short it's just not in
Annie's character it's a juvenile prank
that she doesn't find funny
she's a goody two-shoes who gets mad
about her pens not a prankster out to
cause chaos and fear across the campus
but you know who would enjoy this sort
of prank Britta in season one we learned
the type of pranks that she likes and
they're well they're just kind of lame
in there frog and tomorrow when Senor
Chang's class is coming in there will be
a frog on his desk when where oh you're
done and at the end of this episode
Britta commits the Freudian slip of
typing her name instead of the bandit
onto her project but given that she
can't even say bagel properly it's a
pretty easy detail to overlook know the
suspicions on Britta actually go a lot
deeper Britta doesn't have an alibi for
any of the for cracking x' that we see
and we know that she has regular access
to change
she's also the single likeliest person
to be upset at all the time that Annie
and Jeff are spending together trying to
solve the case so that part of the
bandits phone call would make sense if
it's coming from Britta the victimology
also makes sense for Britta Troy broke
up with Britta at the end of season four
so it's conceivable that she'd want to
crack him given Duncan's general
creepiness towards Britta not a surprise
that she would want to crack him as well
and in season two she was just coming
off the heels of being rejected by Jeff
so again a spree of cracking immediately
after getting dumped except there are
two main pieces of physical evidence
with Britta as the culprit and it all
begins with the first note from the
Bandit that we see in the episode which
contains even more lines that are left
unread on camera if you pause the moment
when the letter is shown and zoom in you
can see this line that's not read aloud
quote it's not my hand that drops the
coin it's God's and that is something
Britta would never say even if it was
joking even if it was trying to make a
point yeah but your religion isn't the
same as morality and Kali
a moral because I'm atheistic is
religious persecution but it's not just
that note here either physical evidence
on the Bandit is slim but there is a bit
that we can use to finally eliminate
Britta once and for all in this shot
right before Troy's cracking we get to
see the Bandit standing relative to a
real-world object a six shelf school
library bookcase researching these sorts
of shelves we know that they're
typically seven feet tall or about 2.1
meters the Bandit is standing around the
height of the sixth one putting his or
her height between five foot ten and six
feet tall or just around one point seven
seven meters the actress who plays
Britta Gillian Jacobs is only five foot
four inches and while Britta may wear
high boots throughout the series a six
inch platform heel is just crazy even
for her it can't be Britta which leaves
us with one Abed Abed is known for
pulling the strings around campus to
make real life feel more like a TV show
now what you have done tell me I got 24
hours to solve the case they do you have
24 hours to solve it to Ralph
that's the poster and yet he's oddly
disinterested in the crime drama that's
happening around him
can't you just stand at the singing of
the crime and see what happened I see a
man using a social disorder as a
procedural device pain painful writing
hurts could it be he doesn't want to be
in the role of the detective because
he's already in the role of the criminal
it does seem unlikely given that he'd
have to crack his own best friend in the
course of this episode but he's been
shown to be willing to hurt his own
friends for the sake of a bit before so
this wasn't a real conversation you were
doing another movie this is why we don't
hang out and here's the thing he has no
real alibi during any of the cracking
'he's in fact his behavior is extremely
suspicious in two key moments first
right before Troy's cracking Troy calls
abend and it goes directly to voicemail
potentially because he's right there
lying in wait outside of the study room
more suspicious though is Abed right
before Vicky's cracking during the
assembly to discuss Roy's law for a
split second we can see Abed next to
Dean Pelton through the crowd a few
seconds later he's gone and seconds
after that Vicki gets cracked by someone
under the bleachers is it just a con new
or is it a hint that Abed is the true
culprit let's continue though because
the evidence doesn't stop there Annie is
convinced that the ACB has a shortcut
through the faculty lounge
the bandits most daring spree he cracked
three people in a row my quickest time
was 20 minutes the ACB did it in ten
except here's the thing Abed is shown in
season one to be the best athlete in
Greendale with an unusually fast running
speed even for Troy who himself was a
big-time play school athlete I need you
to run to my office Dean I am NOT best
athlete on campus so what Annie can do
in 20 minutes
Abed can most likely do much faster but
here's the kicker the thing that
absolutely solidifies Abed as our ACB
when it comes to the two main pieces of
physical evidence in the case Abed fits
both Danny Pudi
the actor who plays Abed is 6 foot tall
the exact height that we need him to be
to measure up properly against those
library book cases and the piece of
evidence that absolutely seals the deal
his handwriting matches the ACB's notes
in season 1 episode 21 contemporary
American poultry Abed makes a chart
mapping off the likes and dislikes of
all his fellow study mates on that board
we get a good sample of his handwriting
which we can then compare to both of the
bandits letters in this episode his
capital B's are bubbly just like the
bandits he dots his lowercase eyes just
like the Bandit his lowercase B's P's
and d's all seem to match the bandits
notes but most convincingly of all is
how he writes his lowercase M's two
little humps in one continuous stroke
just like we see in both of the bandits
letters just like a little but the
intricate nature of the ACB's crimes is
consistent with how immersive Abed can
be and his little projects he's one of
the few characters who'd be willing to
commit to a bit for literal years just
to see it pay off and here just like in
the crime dramas that he watches he laid
out clues that would point to everyone
else mentioning God to make Shirley a
suspect
citing Dave Matthews to make Duncan and
Jeff a suspect calling out Jeff and
Annie's relationship to force Britta
into the spotlight cracking his own
friend Troy to avoid suspicion himself
it's
actly how these crime dramas seeped out
red herrings to point to everyone else
until it's finally revealed that the
detective was in on it the entire time
but only Abed has the means the
opportunity the motive and properly fits
all the physical evidence that we have
to do the deed
he only quits his crimes because Pierce
dies at the end of the episode and Troy
leaves on a boat with levar burton
shortly thereafter his life from that
point forward in the series becomes a
lot more serious and his high jinks
become a lot more muted but it's
important to remember Abed didn't assume
the role of ACB to be malicious like the
contrary he did it to help him
understand the world just a little bit
better to relate to others just that
much more it's TV it's comfort it's a
friend you've known so well for so long
you just let it be with you
and it needs to be okay for it to have a
bad day or phone in a day and it needs
to be okay for it to get on a boat with
levar burton and never come back i think
at this point in time we can all relate
to the feeling of comfort that comes
with immersing yourself in a fictional
world but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and a movie
you
[Music]